the news of the day inflation numbers
are out
news flash ain't nothing changing
inflation is not transitory in terms of
price increases the official inflation
numbers that were reported today is the
cpi the core price uh the consumer price
index is at 5.4 percent
the core inflation number if you take
out food and energy is at 4.3 percent
the federal reserve's target
historically has been two percent yet we
are at inflated levels of inflation but
those are the official numbers nobody
believes the official numbers i don't
believe them nobody here believes them
the federal reserve doesn't believe them
wall street doesn't believe them and
consumers don't believe them it is the
open secret of the financial system is
that the official inflation numbers are
not accurate what is true inflation i
don't know
neither does anybody else it is a very
complex thing to try to figure out and
people do their absolute best to try to
actually
get to the end result but nobody knows
what the inflation numbers are all we do
know is that the official numbers are
under accounting what true inflation is
the other piece of this conversation
that is very important is that everyone
in a society does not experience
inflation equally either if you are in
the top 20
of americans from a net worth standpoint
you are much more likely to be a
beneficiary of inflation rather than
have it hurt you if you are in the
bottom 20 of americans you hold no
investable assets you work an hourly job
you live paycheck to paycheck and you
save 100 of your wealth in cash you are
absolutely getting destroyed by
inflation and so even with high levels
of inflation everyone does not
experience it the same and so we've got
a ton of charts we went deep we did tons
of research the best business show
research team john was all over the
interwebs he outsourced some of the
chart creation to the team in new york
he's laughing eventually people will get
that joke but here's all the charts that
we've got rising prices we're going to
start right from the top uscpi is
expected to moderate some in july but
remain elevated news flash we still have
that cpi number coming in
at 5.4
percent exactly what it was in june so
this was inaccurate next up we have
seasonally adjusted changes
from
the preceding month when you start to
break this down now this looks like
somebody typed it up on a typewriter
just to be clear this does not look like
anyone used a computer to create this
but when you start to actually break
down what's here what you can see is
that there are some things that are
going down but some things are
increasing so for example we can look in
july let's say the new vehicle inflation
month over month grew 1.7
from last month to july right from june
to july 1.7
if you look at something like gasoline
2.4
energy commodities in general 2.3 and
then energy as an entire sector 1.6 and
so you can go through this entire chart
and you can literally see point after
point after point including things like
food up 0.7
month over month and so when you start
to understand how high some of this
inflation is you realize that it is
concentrated in certain areas and so if
you go and you actually look at
individual categories like clothing food
or personal care you can see massive
price jumps and so this next table that
we have here comes from the bureau of
labor statistics and it shows month over
month percentage increases in cpi
women's dresses are up 5.5
that's the largest gain since 2012 that
has nothing to do with supply chains
personal care services up 2.2 the
all-time high highest growth month over
month
motor vehicle repairs not buying the
cars new or used the actual repair of
the vehicle up two percent month over
month the absolute highest gain on
record
world record growth in motor vehicle
repair month over month
the vehicle accessories outside of tires
up 1.6 pets and pet products up 1.4 and
the food away from home they literally
break it down so it's not just food you
eat at your home it's also food away
from home posted a 0.8 month-over-month
gain this is not over a year this is
literally from june to july the food
away from your home
had the largest gains since 1981.
absolutely bonkers and if we go and we
look just all items in a u.s city on
average you can see the year-over-year
comparison this is crazy in over 13
years
this is the highest that we've had on
record
and so when you start to see these types
of numbers it begs the question
can we separate the conversation between
inflation as a rate of change
versus a price increase and i'll get to
that in a second but the other piece
here is the select components of cpi
used cars and trucks
are almost off the chart i mean
literally it it's just
zooming we are just popping we're going
to mars on the new cars and trucks uh on
this chart and then on the other chart
that we have is the used cars so new
cars and trucks literally were just off
the chart going to mars and then when we
break it down by actual components of
cpi used cars and trucks on the far
right again 41
year-over-year change energy up 23
commodities outside of food and energy
up eight percent and if you even look at
food and shelter those are both 2.8 3.4
they are above the fed's 2
target and so when you start to actually
look at this you can see that this is
not just the supply chain disruptions
around housing or around energy or
around some sort of vehicle creation
this is across sectors apparel clothing
is up four percent over the last 12
months absolutely bonker numbers when
you think about a society that is built
on the premise that the increase of
prices will only be about two percent
so when we start to think about this it
is important to remember that words
matter the nomenclature that is used is
very very important you will hear people
say inflation is transitory and what
they are explicitly stating is that the
rate of change that 5.4
in cpi over the last 12 months is the
rate at which inflation has changed in
these goods
that won't continue to be over 5 in the
future
well that essentially would mean that
inflation was compounding and so that we
would have to continue to grow at more
and more faster pace
in the future of course that's not going
to happen that's not how math happens
cars are not going to be
worth millions and millions of dollars
they only can go up so much
but what it doesn't
explain
is that the price increase
is not going away so while the rate of
change measured as inflation today
is not going to
continue to stay at inflated levels
the price increases that society is
experiencing
and the bottom 45 percent of americans
are getting hurt by are here to stay
chipotle
and other fast food restaurants are not
going to decrease their prices in the
future
those car prices that are going up are
unlikely to come down anytime soon
on top of that things like apparel or
other types of goods will continue to be
sold at elevated prices
part of that is because
you have increases in the labor market
if i go to an employee and i say hey i
am now going to pay you 15 an hour
next year i'm not going to come back to
you and say that i'll only pay you 13. i
have to pay you 15 or more into the
future and therefore if labor costs are
going up if the cost of my goods are
going up then i have to increase the
prices of what i sell to my consumer so
that i can pass those
cost increases on to the customer i am
not going to make less money as a
business simply because i have to pay my
employees more you as the end customer
are going to pay more
it is crazy to think
that people
actually want
to explain their prices are going to
come back down they're not going to the
rate of change is going to slow we are
not going to go from 5 to 10 to 15 to 20
over the next three four years because
that would insinuate a doubling tripling
quadrupling of prices in these goods
but as we see a rapid appreciation of
prices you have to remember
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck 78 of americans live paycheck
to paycheck 45 have no investable assets
people are being hurt
and we're pretending
like nobody
should be worried
used cars in america are up 41
over the last 12 months you would have
been better off buying a used car and
flipping it in the last 12 months than
buying the s p 500 the s p 500 is up 33
in the last 12 months used cars are up
41
you would have returned 33
more
than the s p 500 if you would have
bought a car
in the used market and turned around and
sold it now
that's nuts
but that is what has happened hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it